Zara's HQ is a futuristic building known as "The Cube"...
...in La Coruna, northwestern Spain.
From there, staff churn out 30,000 designs a year,...
...near carbon copies of fashion's big names.
Lightning fast, locally targeted designs are Zara's specialty.
When Madonna played three weeks of European concerts in 2001,...
...teenage girls went to her later shows...
...wearing knockoffs of the outfit from her first performance.
Zara's vertically integrated business model limits outsourcing...
...making most of its catwalk copies in-house...
...and ensuring better quality control.
When it does use cheap labor, it goes for poorer European countries...
...rather than the developing world.
Garments hit shop floors within three weeks of design...
...blitzing the industry average of 6 months.